hey everybody welcome to this week in
startups we're trying a new format today
it's called office hours with Jason I'm
Jason
this is my office here at breather if
you go to breather dot-com slash twist
they will give you a full free day at a
breather office they're amazing spaces
where you can work quietly and GSD get
sugar done well today I'm gonna meet
with a bunch of different founders who
have hard questions for me in my office
hours format what's that format you ask
well it's something I do privately where
I book a day every other week and I tell
founders who I've invested and come see
me if you got a problem the door is
always open and bye it's always open I
mean it's open every two weeks well you
get to come into that day today and hear
me interact with my portfolio companies
as well as companies that I might invest
with and I ask them what is their
biggest problem that they can't solve
right now and we brainstorm it so what
you're gonna see here is candid it's
brutal and it's brutally helpful for you
a founder watching the program who wants
to scale their company if you're not
interested in kicking ass if you're not
interested in scaling a company if you
are precious snowflake who's caught up
in your emotions please go watch another
podcast this podcast is for people who
want to win and get rich and get power
and build important companies that
change the world
stick with us okay next up on office
hours with Jason I'm Jason Calacanis is
Emily from the stylist LA how are you hi
I'm good how are you I'm well I'm well
so you're in our accelerator right now
correct yeah how's it going good great
okay well we're here in office hours
which I also do at the accelerator so
you're this is not a new concept to you
I always like to start with what's the
biggest problem you have right now the
hardest thing you're trying to figure
out because if we can figure out your
hardest thing well gosh that could be a
real force multiplier in your company so
what's the hardest thing you're working
on at the stylus tell a and give us like
a one or two sentence description of the
stylus tell a before we hear that
problem okay the stylus tell a is a
woman's contemporary clothing rental
company targeting the millennial and Gen
Z consumer so we have two stores in LA
in San Francisco and we also ship
nationwide so one thing that I'm really
struggling with lately and I want your
Ison is we're in the middle of a
fundraise we're about to close the round
which is great what advice do you have
and what are things that are key things
to watch out for
after you race well that's great
congratulations on the race I hope the
accelerator helped with that yes
definitely
that's definitely yeah so I always
encourage people to sit down with their
management team and you may have a very
light management team because you're a
five or ten person startup right how
many people right now five right now so
I would sit you can sit down with
everybody yeah and say here is the plan
that I've set up for the next 18 months
and I like to do an 18-month plan
because it's not too long but it's also
not too short and it also will be in all
likelihood all likelihood how long your
money will last right so if you were to
raise 1.8 million dollars for simplicity
sake you divide it by 18 it's $100,000 a
month and burn if you raise nine hundred
it's obviously $50,000 right so you're
gonna raise somewhere in that range I
believe yes so amazing around a million
got it so you would have the ability to
burn spend lose $50,000 a month right
and you already have been touching on
profitability correct and you could be
profitable if you wanted to so all that
extra spend is gonna go towards growth
and you should be looking at that spend
and saying in 12 to 18 months where
would where will my revenue because
you're a post product market fit company
and what will drive the next group of
investors typically venture capitalists
- right let's call it a 5 million dollar
check and a proper series a because
you're doing a seed round yes so let's
start with that having been to the
accelerator what do you think you need
to accomplish in the next 12 to 18
months to trigger a series a investment
cuz you've met with series a investors
and gotten a hard no right to early so
what do you think it's gonna take um
three excellent revenue at least I would
say and really having key metrics on
this new subscription that we're
launching so we're launching that in
February and so having key metrics
around that really like hammer down our
cap
also because we haven't spent money on
marketing today so that's something
people really want to know like with
this money behind you what can you
actually get how much are you spending
to acquire customer versus what is their
lifetime value it's the new subscription
okay so what's immediately interesting
about that is you're talking about a new
product line or semi new semi new yeah
we've been testing for two or three
months yeah so you believe that in order
to get the big money in the next round
it's that second revenue stream that has
to click as opposed to the primary one
is that correct well this is something
interesting that I thought about a lot
in the accelerator and not to get off
topic but we were growing at a fine rate
but to be a billion-dollar company I
think that this second revenue stream is
important in tandem with the first got
it so the first one is people come to
the store they rent something one-off
the second one is they commit because
they've had such a great experience
renting a dress for Coachella that they
want to have a address or an outfit
every month rotating through their
closet right okay so now we understand
it so it's not really totally different
now it's just a different way of paying
so you're creating a loyalty program in
a way and gaining more share their
wallet gaining more people love it so
you're basically just taking people who
are one-off customers and getting them
to subscribe so it's actually not that
different I would be concerned if it was
a completely different model right so
now you have to outline okay in order to
triple is your organic growth where will
your current growth trajectory get you
in 12 to 18 months double-double
great so now we know the Delta we know
the difference so you need to get from
600,000 to one you're gonna go from 600
to 1.2 doing what you do but you really
want to get that extra 600,000 so you
slam dunk it and what you should create
is a series of positions in the company
what they will cost and maybe some ideas
about what functions they will do in
order to hit that target and it could be
if you've figured out your CAC and you
figured out how to get customers that
it's opening for startups right I'm
sorry
storefronts it might be that the
storefronts are not are great for
organic growth but maybe the catalyst is
mastering podcasting advertising or
master
influencer marketing and you don't know
the answer to that yet do you we don't
and who's gonna be the person who
determines the tests that get you that
answer our head of marketing you have a
head of marketing and you believe he or
she is capable of doing this yes
definitely because if not you just told
150,000 people you don't believe in them
say another way do they have the
resources to actually run enough tests
to do this yes okay do they need a
second lieutenant
do they need a budget yet have you
thought about that I've thought about it
um I've definitely thought about it I
have a few different scenarios that I'm
playing around with just to see where
the fundraise ends up and like what our
revenue looks like for the next few
months but yes and then we might get
someone to help them that's something
that really we've been thinking about so
now what you need to do is align the
entire organization around what is not a
radically different plan it's hey we're
here is our plan to double we would have
done that off of revenues or a modest
investment we got a bigger investment so
now we have to triple make sure
everybody on the team has bought into
that you have to just look everybody in
the eye and say have you bought into
tripling revenue are you ready to go on
this adventure with us and no matter
what the five of us are going to make
this happen and you got to get a
confirmation from each one of them
because sometimes to start the fact the
founding team that got you here is not
the team that will get you there right
for one of two reasons the first reason
they don't have the ability
the second reason they don't have the
motivation so this is a good time for
you to check in with all five of them
and reconfirm that they are going to not
be snowflakes and not be all in their
feelings and all this it doesn't have to
be crazy at work non hustle blast
nonsense that's going on in the world
right now
right you got to make sure you actually
have hustlers you want to sacrifice and
get to that series day because this is
the critical moment for you if you do
not triple your revenue I'll tell you
what happens to a lot of companies they
raise this money they don't triple
revenue the VCS don't want them which is
not enough growth they've proven to the
VCS that they're not worthy of a Series
A and they can't do it which means
either the markets not there the
founders aren't good at what they do or
the products not that good whatever
reason they will DQ you and then the
angel community and the seed community
will say well we don't want to we've
already seen this it's also proven it
can't get there I'm not going to just
give them a bridge funding to nowhere
it's a little scary right yeah it's sort
of like you left on the boats but
there's not enough provisions to go back
it's good it's like do or die it's like
you you know there's certain airplanes
that if you leave and you fly them to
Hawaii there's a point of no return
right and you just know like if you're
getting to Hawaii or you're landing in
the water yeah congratulations that's
the flight you're about to take yeah I'm
right for it yeah and so you just have
to be the the really great part of that
is if it's a seaplane you can land it so
in this analogy which is flawed if you
actually get to profitability in this
and you're frugal oh my god that creases
your optionality yeah so that's one
thing to keep in mind as you build your
plan and then you want to have a regular
check-in on your plan and make sure you
have all your analytics and the entire
organization set up and modeled around
these very clear metrics so you know
your CAC you know the number of
customers you need you know the margin
you need you know the number of stores
you know how much you have to spend you
know the team size that can all change
you could you certainly will adjust it
as you go
but teams that have a plan and execute
against a plan have a much higher rate
of success in hitting goals than teams
who do not seems obvious yeah but it
really is important for you to have that
plan and communicated with the team and
then it's a good time for you to think
about if any of these people are not
capable of hitting this next level so
every now and then like a band breaks
out and they start doing like concert
halls and it's like wow our drummer is
not that good and they replace their
drummer and that's okay
there was some more important is that
the band succeed yeah so some members of
this band don't belong sorry if you're
watching you need to either step up and
practice harder or get out yeah so
helpful yeah very helpful any other
follow-ups yes so I don't want to think
about the next round yet but you say 18
months of runway when do you think like
I've already started talking to firms
that were too early for so I know who I
have in mind for the next round but when
do I actually initiate contact with them
so we've talked about the importance of
monthly updates and you're one of our
existing investments so you've already
contractually agreed to get me ten
updates a year
and we read them and we respond to some
of them and so it costs you nothing to
say to all those folks I've gone ahead
and puts you on my monthly update if you
don't want to get it let me know but I
took the liberty of putting you on our
monthly updates and then use that
monthly update and putting a chart up
top and owning the metrics put the soft
metrics at the bottom if at all you
spoke at TEDx you went to web some and
all kind of nonsense that does nothing
for revenue driving yeah all the charts
and your CAC and really considered stuff
up top then all those investors gonna
look at and what they'll do is in month
four they'll say you know I'm really
impressed with how this has grown would
you come in and just give us an update I
guarantee you that will happen and then
now is a great time for you to go to
each of those investors and say to them
what would it take to do the series a
what do you think we would have to hit
for it to be worth you taking to your
partners just curious
we had the meeting we got the funding
I'm just curious at what point should we
contact you again and give you an update
was there a revenue number you had in
mind would we have to hit 300 a month
200 a month that would be really helpful
if you told me the exact number okay
awesome be bold like that yeah but
you're already bold so I know that been
great working with you I think you think
you're gonna change the world thank you
I feel like I'm going to as well this is
your moment don't pick it up like
literally this is really your moment you
got like it's very hard to get that
first 500,000 million dollar investment
you really really need to focus and
dedicate your life to this moment for
the next year yeah that's powerful that
might be the most important thing you
just said okay this is your year don't f
it up I'm ready for it okay good luck
alright we'll be right back with another
office hours interaction